While I'm normally opposed
to using puns in videos,
this one's pretty
good, you gotta admit.
Anyhow, my name is Colt McAnlis.
And after posing a question
to the Android Performance
Patterns Google+ Community,
we realized that it might be
beneficial to cover a very
useful tool inside of Android
Studio.
See, one of the biggest
problems with fixing performance
in your applications is that
it's mostly a reactive process.
You build an app,
ship it to users,
and only after they've started
complaining about it do you
know where the problems are.
It seems like it
would be tons easier
to identify the
problems ahead of time
rather than having to wait
for bad reviews to come in.
Now historically,
the Android toolchain
provided a tool named LINT, a
static code analysis tool which
checks your Android
project source
files for any potential
bugs alongside
potential optimizations
for correctness, security,
performance, usability,
accessibility,
and internationalization.
For example, if you're
allocating objects inside
of the onDraw function
which, as we all know,
can lead to excessive
amounts of memory churn,
LINT can detect that and spit
out a nice warning for you,
pinpointing the exact line
that the problem occurs at.
Simply boot up your
favorite command
prompt, run some commands,
and LINT will do the rest.
Well, the good news is that
this handy tool, by default,
is now integrated into
Android Studio 1.0,
and it's useful in
a couple of ways.
Firstly, anytime you want
to kick off a release build,
LINT will run a
subset of its checks
against your compiling code.
Secondly, if you want feedback
on a more regular basis,
you can configure Gradle to run
the full suite of LINT tests
during any various random
build you may kick off
during the day.
And thirdly, if having
LINT run during your builds
isn't really your thing, you
can kick off manual builds
at your discretion.
And just for the sake
of introductions,
let's take a look at
that third step for now.
To run LINT on your code
inside of Android Studio,
open up your project, and
select Analyze, Inspect
Code from the menu.
This will kick off LINT
and present a handy suite
of results that manifest
itself in a window
at the bottom of the IDE.
This bottom window has
two main components.
On the left is a hierarchical
grouping of various errors,
warnings, and potential issues.
And when you select one of
the issues in that left pane,
the right pane will be
filled in with details
about what that problem means,
the line number that causes it,
information on the test, and how
to potentially fix the problem.
If you've noticed by
running this tool,
there's a flood of tests
that LINT checks for.
So if you want to control
the tsunami of information
that LINT can spit out, you
can configure what analysis
you're interested in by opening
File, Other Settings, Default
Settings, and then
selecting Inspections.
This will list all-- and I mean
all-- of the inspecting options
for LINT.
To specifically tune LINT
to find performance issues,
you can search for the
"performance" keywords.
From there, you
can click through
and get a better sense of
what checks are being run,
enable them, disable them,
and reassign their priority
for performance.
But even with that
search, there's
lots of data that's
being listed.
So here are Colt's personal
suggestions on which
ones to keep an eye on.
Firstly, make sure you
set memory allocations
within drawing code
to throw an error.
As we've seen with the
Memory Churn videos,
this can quickly
cause a problem.
And it's worth keeping an eye
on in order to avoid issues here
in the future.
The Layout Has Too Many
Views and Layout Hierarchy
Is Too Deep are good
to keep an eye on.
Although if your users are
running on modern devices,
this may be fine to
just leave as a warning.
And finally, I like to
leave the Overdraw check set
to a warning, if anything,
just to keep an eye on what's
changed between builds.
But remember, at
the end of the day,
these are suggestions based
upon what the tooling team has
seen as common problems.
Your code may get flagged
for a particular issue,
but if it's not actually
eating into your frame rate,
don't actually worry about it.
So keep that in mind before
you run off into the weeds
and start refactoring things.
Now if you run this
tool and end up
with a flood of
performance issues,
then make sure you check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns content
for tips and tricks
on how to address these issues.
And of course, don't hesitate
to join our Google+ Community
to get more information on tips
and tricks from people that are
in the trenches.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.